Hi, my name is Seth Ladd, and
welcome to this episode of
"Dart Tips." This is part one
in a series about functions,
the stalwart and trusty building
blocks of any app.
Dart supports top-level
functions, optional
parameters, nested functions,
passing functions as arguments
to other functions, and more.
It's not uncommon to
build an entire
app using only functions.
If you think Dart is only
classes and libraries, you're
in for a treat.
This episode will focus on
defining and calling functions.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Functions are reusable
bundles of logic.
They can take zero or more
arguments, perform some work,
and optionally return a value.
Here's a very simple function
named meaning0fLife().
The empty parentheses means this
function does not take
any parameters.
Use the return statement
to return a value--
in this case, 42.
If no return statement is
specified, the function
returns null.
Here's how you call
this function.
So far, so good.
But Dart likes to be a terse
language, so we can simplify
the definition of this function
into a single line.
This fat arrow syntax is
syntactic sugar for a more
terse way to return the
resulting value of the
expression on the right-hand
side of the fat arrow.
Functions can, of course,
accept parameters.
Here's an example.
This code works just fine,
but this is Dart.
We have optional type
annotation, so we can annotate
this method's parameters
and return type.
We strongly recommend using
type annotations on the
surface area of your code.
Any code that another user will
interact with, functions
being a perfect example, should
annotate what types it
expects and what type
it returns.
Your fellow developers will
thank you, and your tools will
give you even better feedback.
Functions can take multiple
parameters.
Here's an example.
This function has two required
parameters-- a string for the
message and an integer for the
number of exclamation points
to add at the end.
Exclamation points are loud,
no doubt about it.
But sometimes, you may not
want to shout so loud.
Of course, one option is to pass
0 at the end as a second
parameter, like this
code shows.
However, it is hard to read
this line of code.
A casual observer may not know
what this magic 0 is.
Also, wouldn't it be better to
simply leave off the second
parameter if you don't
want to use it?
Luckily, Dart has a way
to make this better.
Wrap one or more parameters with
square brackets to make
them optional.
Here's an example.
Notice how the function now
checks if exclamations is
null, which is the value of the
parameter if it was not
provided by the caller.
Now that the second parameter
is optional, you can
optionally omit it when
you call the function.
Here's an example.
We made this function more
flexible and easier to use.
However, there is still
another problem here.
The second parameter, if it is
provided, still looks a bit
like a magic number.
That is, the casual observer
would not know what this magic
number 5 means.
Luckily, Dart has a solution
for this, too.
You can make methods even
easier to read by using
optional named parameters.
Here's an example.
I think adding a simple name
to the parameter makes it
obvious what is going on.
To define optional named
parameters, wrap the
parameters in curly braces.
To briefly recap, there are two
ways to define optional
parameters--
square brackets for optional
positional parameters and
curly braces for optional
named parameters.
There's yet another benefit
from the use of optional
parameters.
But first, the setup.
Sometimes there's an
obvious or default
answer for a parameter.
Only on occasion does it make
sense to pass in something
more unique.
For example, here's a function
that opens an HTTP connection.
The first parameter IP
address could be
anything, so it's required.
However, almost all HTTP
connections use port 80, so
the second parameter
can be optional.
The function is easier to use
now, because the user doesn't
have to specify the obvious.
However, the code inside the
function is a bit verbose.
Plus, there's no way to express
to the user what the
port's value is if it
is not provided.
Luckily, Dart lets us specify
a default value for a
parameter if that parameter
is optional.
Here's an example.
This code is simpler, the
semantics are more clear, and
it is self-documenting.
You can use any compiled time
constants, such as integer
literals, as shown here,
for default values.
Here are some examples of
using this function.
However, here is an
example that might
not be totally clear.
Notice how I am passing null
as the second parameter.
Null is a perfectly
valid value.
So in this case, port will be
set to null, even though it
has a default value.
The lesson here is that default
values are only
applied if the caller
does not supply any
value for the parameter.
This means, to really cover your
bases, you should check
for null even when you
use default values.
This brings up a
good question.
In the case of an optional
parameter without a default
value, can you tell the
difference between a user
passing in null and not passing
in anything at all?
The parameter will be
null either way.
It turns out that Dart does
indeed have a way to ask if an
optional parameter
was provided when
the method was called.
Just use the question mark
parameter syntax.
Here's an example.
Like the optional named
parameters, you can use
default values with optional
positional parameters.
There is a syntax difference,
though.
You must use equals with
the positional
params instead of colon.
Here's an example of defining
an optional positional
parameter with a
default value.
Moving on, you can define
functions simply at the top
level of your code.
Here's an example.
I love this, because it means I
don't need to wrap functions
assigned [? to ?] classes.
Writing a simple script with
Dart is easy because of
top-level functions.
Now you know that functions
can capitalize on type
annotations, have both optional
positional and
optional named parameters, have
default values for their
optional parameters, and more.
There's a lot more to
functions in Dart.
And we'll cover nested
functions, functions as
objects, and more in
a future episode.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Seth Ladd.
And as we say here on "Dart
Tips," stay sharp.
Click here to subscribe to our
channel for more episodes of
"Dart Tips." We appreciate any
thoughts you might have for
this series.
Please leave them in
the comments below.
And if you have any additional
questions about Dart, please
drop by Stack Overflow where
Dart experts are standing by
to help you out.
See you next time.